さて、河野さんは、東日本大震災が起こったとき、
どういうことしてらっしゃってたか
覚えてらっしゃいますか。
東京の郊外に実家があるんですが、そこにいて、
かなりあのような地震があって驚いたんですけれども、
とにかく情報をと思ってテレビをつけると、
リアルタイムであの津波の映像のほうが流れて
かなりショックを受けていましたね。
私はちょうどそのとき、JR山手線の
浜松町の駅のホームにいたんですけれども、
周りのビルが本当に大きく揺れて、大変驚きました。
またその日、ある場所で会議をすることに
なってたんですけれども、会議をしたんですが、結局、
宿泊先にも戻れなくて、それでその研究所で
同僚の人たちと一緒にテレビを見ながら、この地震、
そのあとの津波の様子を見て一夜を過ごしました。
福島の第一原子力発電所をはじめとして、
東日本の太平洋側にはたくさん
原子力発電所がありますけれども、
これどうなってるか本当に心配だったんですが、
最初は、冷温停止をしたとそういう報道も
ありましたので安心をしていたんですけれども、
実は大変な事故につながったってわけですね。
で、未曾有の大地震とそれに続く大津波、
さらにそれらに起因する福島第一原子力発電所の
事故というのは、科学技術と社会の関係を大きく変えて、
そこで新しい時代を生み出したというふうに
私は思います。で、大地震と津波という
自然災害にどういうふうに備えるかと、
防災の観点からも、この震災っていうのは、
われわれに考えるべきことは
多く与えてくれたわけですけれども、
特にこの科目では技術者倫理の観点から、
この福島第一原子力発電所の事故に注目をして
考察をしてみたいと考えています。
ところで河野さんは、この事故の原因というのは
どういうものであったかっていうのはご存じでしょうか。
確か、直接の事故の原因というのは、
地震と津波による影響で核燃料の冷却のための必要な
電源がすべてなくなると、ステーションブラックアウト、
いわゆる全電源喪失というふうに
いわれていますけれども、そういった事態になって、
で、核燃料を冷却できなくなってしまったということが
原因だというふうに指摘されています。
事故の直接な原因については、今、
河野さんが言ってくれたとおりなんですけれども、
詳細は参考文献やこの科目のテキスト教材っていうのを
読んでいただきたいと思います。
事故の原因については、いくつかの
調査報告書ってのが提出されていますよね。
民間のものもありますし、政府が出してるものも
ありますけれども、ここでは国会の
東京電力福島第一原子力、長いんですけれども、
事故調査委員会いわゆる国会事故調といってますけども、
ここの報告書に注目をしてみたいと思います。
国会事故調は、福島第一原子力発電所の
事故っていうのは人災であるというふうに
結論づけています。委員長を務められた黒川清先生は、
次のように述べてらっしゃるわけですね。
福島原子力発電所の事故は終わってはいないと、
これは世界の原子力の歴史に残る大事故であり、
科学技術先進国の一つである日本で起きたことに
世界中の人々が驚愕したと。ここが大事なんですけども、
想定できたはずの事故がなぜ起こったのか、
その根本原因は、日本が高度経済成長を遂げた頃にまで
遡ると。政界、官界、財界が一体となり、
国策として共通の目標に向かって進む中、
複雑に絡まった規制のとりこ、
レギュラトリーキャプチャーというふうに
呼ばれますけどもこれが生まれたのだというわけですね。
実際、事故が起こってすぐの頃は、多くの人たちが、
今回のような大きな津波が起こることは想定外だった、
そして、すべての電源を失う、
全電源喪失っていうのも想定外である、
こういうことを言っていたんですけれども、
国会事故調の報告では、津波も全電源喪失というのも
想定すべきことであったし、実際に想定されていた、
こういうことを報告書では明らかにされています。
それにもかかわらず、事故前に地震や津波に対する
対策を取ることができなかったのは、規制のとりこが
原因であると結論づけているわけですけども、
ここで規制のとりこというのは経済の用語なんですが、
規制する側、今回の場合は当時の経済産業省の
原子力・安全保安院あるいは内閣府の中の
原子力安全委員会でありますけれども、
ここの規制するべき側が規制される側、事業者ですね、
東京電力をはじめとする、こういう規制される側に
情報や技術力で圧倒されていて
コントロールされてしまっていた、
そういうような状況を察して
規制のとりこというふうに呼んでおります。
で、国会事故調によりますと、原発の安全性を
高めるための新たな規制を導入しようと
そういう意志を持っていた保安院に対して、
東電は情報の優位性などを武器に
規制の先送りでありますとか基準の下方修正を、
さまざまなルートで規制をする側に働きかけていた。
で、また、規制する側も、安全基準を高めると、
既に安全と認めた原発を巡って、訴訟が起きること、
こういうことを心配したようです。さらに、
規制する側である保安院が国策として
原子力発電を推進する立場である
経済産業省の中の一部であった、
こういうことから規制される側である事業者、
東電に取り込まれてしまっていたために、地震や津波、
あるいはシビアアクシデントといわれます
過酷な事故のことをシビアアクシデントといいますが、
これに関して行うべき対策を取るのが遅れたのだ、
こういうふうに指摘をしています。
具体的な例としましては、2006年に定められた
耐震設計の審査指針というのがございますけれども、
これの指針では、すべての原子力事業者に、
新しい基準に従って原発の耐震安全性を再評価、
これはバックチェックというふうにいわれますけども、
これを指示したわけなんですが、
東電では進まなかったわけですね。
また、東電も保安院も、耐震補強工事が必要であると
そういう認識をしていながらも、
当時日本で最も古い原子炉の一つである
福島第一原子力発電所の1号機、
これは1971年に商業運転を始めています。
で、二号機、これもおんなじ年に
商業運転を始めておりますし、3号機、
これは1976年に運転を始めているわけですけれども、
こういう古い原子炉に対して
工事をしていなかったんですね。
このことを保安院側は、ある意味黙認していたわけです。
報告書では、1号機から3号機の地震や津波に対する
脆弱性というのは認識をされていたと、
そしてその対策を取る機会は何度もあったと、
にもかかわらず、その対策っていうのはなされなかった、
こういうことを指摘しているわけですね。
全電源喪失であったりとか炉心融解などっていうのは、
想定外ではなくって、海外では実際に想定されていた、
実際、その対策も取られていたそうですよね。
日本の原子力関係者はなぜ
その対策が取れなかったんでしょうか。
いろいろあると思いますけれども、自ら、
自分たちの原子力の技術の高さ、これにある意味で
慢心していたということがあったんでしょうね。
全電源喪失なんていうそういう事態は
絶対起こらないというふうに
考えていたんだのかもしれません。
ともかく、国会事故調は、報告書の結論の部分で
こういうふうに言ってます。広範囲に及ぶ巨大地震、
津波という自然災害とそれによって引き起こされた
原子力災害への対応は極めて困難なものであった、
これは疑いもないことであると、
そういうふうに断ったうえで、
しかしながらというわけですね。
しかしながら、このスライドにありますように、
当時の政府、規制当局、そして事業者は、
原子力のシビアアクシデントにおける心の準備や、
各自の地位に伴う責任の重さへの理解、そして
それを果たす覚悟はあったんだろうかと、
この事故が人災であることは明らかで、
歴代及び当時の政府、規制当局、そして事業者である
東京電力による、人々の命と社会を守ると、
そういう責任感の欠如があったんだ、
こういうふうに結論部分で述べているわけですね。
さらに、日本が持つ制度的な問題、
これを指摘をしたうえで、次のように述べています。
まず一つ目は、関係者に共通していたのは、
およそ原子力を扱う者に許されない無知と慢心であって、
世界の潮流を無視して国民の安全を最優先とはしないで、
組織の利益を最優先とする組織依存のマインドセット、
思い込みだとか常識、そういったものがあったんだと。
このように技術者を含めて関係者の人たちを
糾弾しているわけです。この指摘を、
河野さん、どういうふうにお考えですか。
大変厳しい指摘だとは思うんですが、
的は射てるかなというふうに思う一方で、じゃあ、
自分自身に振り返ってみると、
自分自身の立場が負っている責任っていうのを
考える続けるってことの難しさっていうのも、
改めて、また感じるところではあるかなと思いますね。
本当にそのとおりだと思います。で、ここで、
原子力関係者だけではなくて、すべての技術者は
この批判を真摯に受け止めるべきだというふうに
思いますね。そのうえで新しい時代の技術者は、
どういうふうに意思決定をして、どういうふうに
行動すればいいのか、また、科学技術と社会との
関係の中でどのような役割を担うべきなのか、
こういうことを考えていく必要があると思います。
そもそも絶対に安全な技術というのは
世の中には存在しないわけですね。
もちろんそう、原理的には
絶対にというのはあり得ないわけですよね。
そうすると、なぜ原理的に絶対安全な技術っていうのは
存在しないのか、これはテキストのほうに
書いてありますので、基本的な考え方、
あるいはリスクに関しての基本的な考え方っていうのは、
参考資料でありますとかテキストを
参照していただきたいと思います。
で、原子力をはじめとして高度化する
複雑化する技術を利用することっていうのは、
本質的にリスクを伴うわけです。で、さらに
そのリスクは拡大傾向にあります。そのため、
技術を社会に持ち込む専門家であるところの
技術者の責任として、技術の持つリスクについて
深く考察をする必要があると思います。
技術者倫理の第1原則というところでは、
公衆の安全であったりとか健康、福利というのを
最優先して職務を遂行することだというふうに
聞いているんですけども、ある意味では、
自分が携わっている技術の領域だけで
この原則を守ればいいっていうふうに
考えられると思うんですが、
それ以上のことってのは求められてるんでしょうか。
本当に非常に重要な問いかけだと思います。
それが、私の言うところの、
まさしく新しい時代の技術者に
求められていることであるのではないか、
それを考えるうえで重要な問いだと思います。
もう新しい時代の技術者には、すべての技術が
何らかのリスクを伴う以上、その技術を
受け入れるかどうか、技術について
どの程度までのリスクを許容するのか、
そういう問いに対して社会的な合意が
形成される必要があるわけですけども、
その合意が形成するまでに技術者を含む専門家が
積極的に関与していく、こういうことが新しい時代には
ますます求められるようになってきていると思います。